Bienvenidos a Barrow, Alaska: la ciudad más
al norte del mundo. También es conocida por
su nombre inuit, UTQUAGVIK. El paquete de
bacon por esta tierra cuesta 15 dólares,
un pequeño saco de harina sale por 20 dólares
y una bolsa de pan de molde cuesta 6 dólares.
El suelo está congelado durante la mayor
parte del año, así que las casas no pueden
tener cimientos. Tampoco hay carreteras que
conecten esta ciudad así que la única forma
de llegar es por avioneta o… en trineo.
A estas alturas, la gran pregunta que muchos
os estaréis haciendo es ¿Cómo es posible
que haya 5000 personas viviendo aquí? ¿Quién
vendría a vivir aquí? En general ¿Quién
querría vivir en un estado como Alaska y,
a la vez, porque es un estado tan importante
para estados unidos? Al final de este vídeo
entenderéis por qué Alaska es uno de los
estados más ricos de todo Estados Unidos
y, a la vez, sufre una de las crisis financieras
más terribles del país ¡Vamos con ello!
Alaska es el estado más grande de Estados
Unidos: al menos, en lo que a territorio respecta.
Ahora bien, tiene menos de 1 millón de habitantes.
Apenas hay carreteras y casi todo el transporte
se realiza por avión. De hecho, tienen una
de las tasas más altas de pilotos de avión
per cápita de todo el mundo.
¿Y qué me decís del clima? En Alaska hace
tanto frío, que hasta los de Burgos se tienen
que poner un abrigo (vale, esta broma sólo
la entenderéis los de España…). En invierno,
las temperaturas pueden alcanzar los 40 grados
bajo cero. Y prácticamente todos los productos
se tienen que importar desde muy lejos. Esto
significa que absolutamente todo en este país
es ridículamente caro. En otras palabras:
Alaska es el último lugar donde nadie viviría.
Quiero decir: imaginad que fuerais un millonario
y pudierais vivir donde quisieras ¿De verdad
os mudaríais a Alaska? Pues… ¡Tal vez
sí! Alaska es el 5º estado de Estados Unidos
en población millonaria. El 6,75% de su población
son, técnicamente, millonarios. Su PIB per
capita es el 7º más alto de todo el país:
73.000 dólares. Y, todos los años, los alasqueños
reciben un cheque del estado ¡Sólo por vivir
ahí!
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué Alaska es tan
increíblemente rico? La respuesta se puede
resumir en una palabra: PETRÓLEO. Ya lo sé,
seguro que nadie se lo había esperado. El
zumo de dinoaurio ha convertido a Alaska en
la Noruega de los USA. Pero, si seguís VisualPolitik
con regularidad, ya sabréis que vivir del
petróleo en tiempos del coronavirus no es
un buen negocio. Atentos.
Alaska encara un triple golpe del coronavirus
debido a su dependencia del petróleo, la
pesca y el turismo
Os lo hemos dicho un millón de veces aquí,
en VisualPolitik: los recursos naturales suelen
ser más una maldición que una ventaja. Y
Alaska no tiene un problema de dependencia
del petróleo: podemos hablar directamente
de adicción. Así que, en cuanto los precios
del petróleo caen, los alasqueños sufren
más que nadie. Todo esto explica que, desde
el año 2014, Alaska está en recesión. Tal
cual como lo oís. Mientras Estados Unidos
ha experimentado un auténtico boom, el PIB
de Alaska no ha dejado de caer. Y ahora, con
la pandemia del coronavirus, las cosas van
de mal en peor.
Pero la pregunta es… ¿Cómo de mal? ¿De
verdad la vida en Alaska es tan terrible?
¿Por qué Alaska es tan rica y por qué ahora
está sufriendo una recesión? ¿Hay alguna
forma de acabar con el déficit de su estado?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
DESTINO MANIFIESTO
Durante toda la II Guerra Mundial sólo hubo
UNA BATALLA en suelo estadounidense (Si no
contamos con el ataque a Peal Harbor, claro)
¿A que no adivináis donde? Pues sí, fue
la batalla de ATTU, en Alaska. Los japoneses
entendieron la importancia estratégica de
Alaska y, por eso, invadieron parte de ella
durante un año. Con esto ya nos podemos hacer
una idea de lo importante que es este estado…
pese a que esté en mitad de ninguna parte.
En el año 1867, Estados Unidos compró Alaska
por 7,2 millones de dólares: ¡Toda una ganga,
oiga! Básicamente, pagaron 2 céntimos de
dólar por acre. Por aquel entonces, Alaska
era una colonia rusa. Pero, en realidad, ningún
ruso vivía por ahí. La población de este
terreno eran, prácticamente en su totalidad,
INUITS (Y aquí hago un paréntesis: los Inuits
son lo que, comúnmente llamamos esquimal.
Pero el término esquimal es extremadamente
ofensivo. Así que ya lo sabéis por si un
día os encontráis con uno).
Y diréis ¿Para qué quería Estados Unidos
comprarse Alaska? En su momento, este acuerdo
fue muy polémico. Pero en seguida se recuperó
la inversión. En el año 1900, miles de estadounidenses
emigraron a estas tierras en lo que se conoció
como la “fiebre del oro”.
Tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial, el ejército
del Aire estableció bases por todo el estado,
creando más puestos de trabajo y más oportunidades
para más estadounidenses que hicieron de
este lugar su casa. Pensadlo bien: Alaska
está al lado de Rusia, y esto era importante
durante la Guerra Fría.
Sin embargo, el auténtico despegue económico
de Alaska llegó en los años 60. En 1959,
Alaska se convirtió en el cuadragésimo noveno
estado de la Unión. En ese momento, ya tenían
más de 222.000 habitantes, que era tres veces
más que en 1940. Pero en 1968 se descubrieron
enormes yacimientos de petróleo. Sin embargo,
la fiebre del oro negro no llegó hasta años
más tarde. Pensadlo bien, el petróleo de
Alaska no estaba, precisamente, en una zona
cómoda y accesible. Estaba en la zona norte,
justo donde está la ciudad de Barrow. Y para
hacer llegar ese zumo de dinosaurio al resto
del país hacía falta construir un oleoducto
de 1300 kilómetros. Echad un vistazo a este
mapa.
En otras palabras… que en un principio,
el petróleo de Alaska era de todo menos rentable…
hasta que un día, las cosas cambiaron.
The oil producing countries in the arab world
decided to use their oil as a political weapon.
Exacto: en el año 1973, las petromonarquías
declararon un embargo de petróleo. De repente,
los costes del crudo se dispararon. Y, de
repente, lo que parecía una obra faraónica
se convirtió en una necesidad. Bastaron dos
años para que Estados Unidos construyera
el oleoducto.
Y esto nos lleva de vuelta a Barrow. Barrow
es la ciudad donde se descubrió el mayor
yacimiento de petróleo no convencional de
toda Norte América. Así que ya sabéis por
qué hay 5000 personas viviendo en este pueblo.
En realidad, Alaska es un territorio lleno
de recursos naturales: petróleo, gas, metales,
bosques, potencial para energías renovables
y… ¡pescado!
La industria del pescado no es cosa de broma.
Sólo entre 2017 y 2018, Alaska procesó más
de 2 millones y medio de toneladas de pescado.
Hablamos de una industria de 5.600 millones
de dólares que emplea a 60.000 personas.
De hecho, uno de cada dos pescados que se
come en todo Estados Unidos viene de Alaska.
Alaska también es uno de los lugares con
más millonarios de todo Estados Unidos.
En otras palabras: podemos decir que Alaska
es la Noruega de Estados Unidos. Ambos tienen
una economía basada en petróleo y pescado,
ambos están en el norte y ambos son muy ricos.
Sin embargo hay una diferencia. La economía
de Noruega crece de forma estable mientras
que Alaska está en una terrible recesión
¿Por qué? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
CUANDO EL PETRÓLEO YA NO PAGA LAS FACTURAS
Si hay un estado con problemas, ese es, sin
duda Alaska. De entrada, tiene un problema
de aislamiento, que sube los costes de cualquier
cosa: coches, medicinas, comida… cualquier
cosa es más cara en Alaska. Incluso la capital
del Estado, JUNEAU, está aislada del resto
del Estado: no tiene carreteras que la conecten
con ninguna otra ciudad. Así que la única
forma de llegar es mediante aviones o barcos.
Desde el punto de vista de los servicios públicos,
Alaska es una auténtica pesadilla. Un estado
del tamaño de Libia pero con la población
de Frankfurt. La densidad de población es
terriblemente baja.
Y, precísamente por estas razones, los alasqueños
no pagan impuestos estatales. Tal vez esta
sea la razón por la que tantos millonarios
viven por aquí. Y diréis: si no cobran impuestos…
¿Cómo se financia el estado? La respuesta
es el petróleo y los recursos naturales.
Casi todos los ingresos del estado vienen
de los royalties que cobran por explotar los
recursos naturales y los impuestos a las grandes
empresas.
Y diréis ¡Pues no suena nada mal! Sólo
pagan impuestos las grandes petroleras. Fantástico
¿verdad? Pues… no exactamente. Atentos
a esta noticia.
La producción de petróleo de la costa Norte
de Alaska tendrá su año fiscal más bajo
desde que comenzó el oleoducto.
¡Exacto! El boom del petróleo de Alaska
ha terminado. En realidad, ahora mismo se
saca el petróleo justo y necesario para evitar
que todo el sistema de oleoductos se congele.
Y esto ha ocurrido por una combinación de
factores. El primero es la competencia. Es
decir, Alaska no es el único estado con petróleo.
Otros estados como Texas o las dos Dakotas
también han tenido sus fiebres del oro negro.
Y estos estados tienen la ventaja de no estar
en el ártico: no es necesario enviar trabajadores
al fin del mundo para extraer crudo, ni tampoco
hay que enviarlo a través de un oleoducto
de 1300 kilómetros. Además, el barril apasqueño
es uno de los más caros de extraer. Para
que Alaska saque un beneficio de su barril,
el precio tiene que estar por encima de los
59 dólares.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el momento
en el que hacemos este vídeo, el barril de
brent está en 55.89. Pero ha llegado a estar
mucho más bajo.
Todo esto explica por qué la caída de precios
de 2014 tuvo un efecto tan dramático en la
economía de Alaska. Mientras el resto del
país estaba creciendo a ritmos del 2.5% del
PIB, Alaska empezaba su super recesión. Su
PIB cayó al 1.5% ese año. En 2015, cayó
el 8%. Y todo esto significa que el gobierno
tenía un grave problema ¿Recordáis que
os he dicho que casi todos los ingresos del
estado vienen de los royalties y los impuestos
sobre los beneficios de las empresas? Pues
adivinad lo que pasa cuando las empresas petroleras,
que son las más importantes de la zona, no
tienen beneficios. De un día para otro, los
ingresos del estado cayeron en un 80%. Y si
esto es lo que pasó en 2014, imaginad lo
que ha ocurrido durante la pandemia del Coronavirus.
Los precios del petróleo de Alaska podrían
caer a niveles record esta semana, añadiendo
más desafíos al estado
A todo esto hay que añadirle el hecho de
que Alaska se está quedando sin petróleo.
Se estima que este estado ya ha extraído
el 60% de sus reservas. Esto explica porque
algunas petroleras como ConocoPhillips están
cortando gastos en Alaska por más de 500
millones de dólares.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque los problemas
no vienen solos. Alaska es una de las regiones
más afectadas por el Cambio Climático. El
Ártico se está calentando dos veces más
rápido que el resto del mundo. Y eso implica
que la acidificación del océano también
puede dar al traste con la única industria
que todavía funciona por aquí: la pesca.
Así que toda esa riqueza de Alaska podría
acabarse más pronto que tarde. La pregunta
ahora es ¿Qué pueden hacer para evitar el
desastre? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL DIVIDENDO ALASQUEÑO
Alaska tiene un problema presupuestario de
proporciones… jordianas (esa no la habéis
visto venir ¿verdad?) El petróleo ya no
da dinero, de hecho, cada vez están produciendo
menos barriles. Eso significa que, prácticamente,
nadie paga impuestos… y los ciudadanos se
están marchando. En otras palabras, si eres
Mike Dunleavy, el actual gobernador de Alaska,
y estás viendo este vídeo, sólo puedo decirte
una cosa: ¡Lo siento!
El presupuesto de Alaska apunta al debate
sobre los cheques de riqueza petrolera
Durante décadas, Alaska construía un montón
de infraestructura y proyectos comunitarios
mientras el precio del petróleo era alto.
Cuando era bajo, cortaba el gasto y cerraba
edificios. Esta vez, los precios no han subido
y, tras años de cortar gastos y consumir
los ahorros, los líderes del estado tienen
que tomar decisiones duras
Y diréis… ¿Qué pueden hacer en el Gobierno
de Alaska? Pues… atentos porque existe una
solución. Durante todo este vídeo hemos
comparado Alaska con Noruega. Pues bien, hay
otra cosa que tienen en común: ambos tienen
un fondo de inversión soberano.
Veréis, en 1976, durante el gran boom del
petróleo apasqueño, el estado creó el Fondo
Permanente de Alaska, financiado con todo
el dinero que llegaba del petróleo y el gas.
Este fondo de inversión está gestionado
por una empresa pública. Ahora bien: hay
una diferencia. El fondo soberano noruego
sirve, principalmente, para pagar las pensiones.
El fondo alasqueño sirve para… Nadie lo
sabe muy bien. Pues bien: eso de tener un
fondo de inversión soberano que no financia
ningún servicio público no es tan mala idea
como parece. Desde el año 1982, todos los
ciudadanos de Alaska cobran el dividendo del
fondo permanente. Es decir, que sólo por
vivir en Alaska, el estado te da dinero ¿Qué
os parece?
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero de cuánto dinero
hablamos? Pues, hasta el año 2008, los alasqueños
cobraban unos 2000 dólares al año. Se estima
que este dividendo ha servido para sacar a
entre 15000 y 25000 alasqueños de la pobreza.
Así que, aunque en Alaska tengan una crisis
gigantesca, el fondo ha servido para evitar
que se generen bolsas de pobreza.
Y diréis ¿Pero cómo de grande es este fondo?
Hablamos de más de 60.000 millones de dólares.
Y por eso, ahora el gobierno está empezando
a pensar que tal vez ese dinero se puede utilizar
para tapar todos los agujeros del estado.
Atentos.
Alaska, que dependía profundamente de los
ingresos de las actividades petroleras, tuvo
que lidiar con problemas fiscales repentinos
echando mano de sus ahorros y cortando el
gasto. Todavía tiene un déficit presupuestario
de 2.500 millones de dólares para el año
que viene.
Alaska ya ha reducido el gasto al mínimo.
Pero todavía necesita reducir más. Y no
parece que el dinero del petróleo vaya a
volver. Por supuesto, podrían crear nuevos
impuestos… pero eso sería una medida muy
impopular. Así que sólo parece que exista
una solución seria: usar los dividendos del
fondo soberano.
Es decir, algunos legisladores quieren usar
un porcentaje de los dividendos del fondo
para financiar el estado. Podría entenderse
como las comisiones que te cobraría cualquier
fondo de inversión comercial. Pero, en este
caso, serviría para financiar el estado de
Alaska. Y os preguntaréis ¿Bastaría con
esto para resolver la crisis fiscal de Alaska?
Y la respuesta es SÍ.
La empresa pública que este fondo ha hecho
un trabajo fantástico. Tienen una cartera
muy diversificada, inversiones conservadores
y un proceso de deliberación muy cuidadoso.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a finales de
2016, el fondo estaba valorado en 55000 millones
de dólares. Ahora mismo, 5 años después,
ha crecido hasta ponerse en los 67.000 millones.
Es decir, que sí, el fondo puede ser más
que suficiente para tapar todos los agujeros
del Estado, o incluso dejar las cuentas en
superavit.
Sin embargo, esto es sólo una solución temporal.
Por supuesto, con esta estrategia, Alaska
puede cubrir su crisis fiscal. Pero no su
crisis económica. Durante décadas, casi
toda la economía de Alaska dependía del
petróleo. Pero ahora necesitan diversificar
y atraer nuevas industrias.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que Alaska terminará usando su
fondo soberano para financiar su estado? ¿Podrá
Alaska diversificar su economía? ¿Qué industrias
creéis que podrían establecerse en este
lugar? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que, en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.